إذن ما الذي يهم إذا تم
تطعيم الناس إذا كان الجميع عرضة
لهذا النوع من الدلتا ،
فلماذا لا لماذا يجب أن يتم تطعيم الناس
جيدًا على الإطلاق ، هناك سبب وجيه حقًا
للحصول على لقاح
كريس وهذا هو إنقاذ حياتك
لمنعك من أن تكون
يمنعك دخول المستشفى من الموت لأن
الشيء الوحيد الذي
يعمل بشكل جيد للغاية مع هذا اللقاح
هو أنه حتى مع متغير دلتا ، فإنه
يمنعك إذا أصبت من الإصابة
بمرض خطير
بما يكفي لوضعك في المستشفى فإنه
يحميك من العدوى بشكل جميل
حسنًا ،
لكن ما تفعله بشكل أفضل هو
منعك من الإصابة بمرض خطير ،
لذلك عندما تحصل على التطعيم لا تحصل على
التطعيم لمجرد أنك لا
تريد ارتداء قناع ،
فأنت تحصل على التطعيم لأنك تريد
إنقاذ حياتك
وصحتك  هو سبب
رغبتك في
ارتداء قناع الآن لأن لدينا موقفًا
حيث إذا أصبت بالعدوى ،
فقد تنشره إلى شخص آخر
تعرفه  هذه مشكلة ثانوية تقريبًا ، فإن القضية
الأساسية في الحصول على التطعيم هي
إنقاذ حياتك ومنعك من الإصابة
بمرض خطير
بسبب النكس السياسي آه قلت إنك
تعلم أنك قلت إنه علم والآن
أنت تغيره
ولم تكن تعرفه في ذلك الوقت  أو لا تعرف
الآن
لا ، فنحن لا نغير العلم الذي
تعرفه ما الذي تغير كريس
تغير الفيروس وتطور العلم
مع الفيروس المتغير الذي كنا
نتعامل
مع فيروس ألفا منذ بضعة أشهر
كما أخبرتك أنه كان  الفيروس الذي إذا كان
الشخص مصابًا بعدوى اختراق ، من
غير المحتمل جدًا أن ينقله هذا الشخص ،
فقد
تغير الآن مستوى الفيروس في
البلعوم
الأنفي لشخص مصاب بالدلتا هو
ألف
مرة مما كان عليه مع ألفا مما
يعني أنه مصاب بالفعل  القدرة ،
وفي الواقع ، في العالم الواقعي
، يمكنها أن تنتقل ، لذا لم يتغير
شيء في العلم
، كان الفيروس هو الذي غيّر أننا
نتعامل مع فيروس مختلف بشكل أساسي